hi there here i am on top of not quite
the top but on cypress bowl snow shoeing
again with mark and with gordy and so i
thought i'd do my their sporty hello
laurie say hello
and uh yeah people said speaking
different languages normally like
there's about five languages that i can
just speak in and then there's another
five that i'd like to warm up refresh
maybe spend a day on link and then
there's another five that i spent a few
days on links but i'm not gonna have
that today i'm just gonna wing it
so
first of all happy new year to everyone
uh
what is it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
best wishes for the new year
uh scratch it i can't i don't even know
how to do it scratch it keep going
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
um
what did i forget cantonese
uh
that's all i can't come up with anything
bye for now all the best i just wanna
still have the thing on you know it's
interesting because
you can't
some people think you have to be able to
say the most simple things in a language
in order to be able to say that you can
speak the language um
you know like how to shy your shoelaces
someone said i don't i don't believe
that to be the case and wishing people
happy new year is not something you
normally do unless you're living in the
country so actually not having prepared
for it i find it difficult had i gone
and prepared and looked up happy new
year and all that in google translate i
would have been able to do a better job
but
it doesn't matter language is about
communicating and so maybe that's the
message for the new year
just worry about communicating and if
you stumble as i did it doesn't matter
as long as you enjoy your language
learning and
all the best bye for now
okay
there we are new years almost day before
on the mountain
conquering where no one has been before
okay bye for now